hi I mean let's talk about it the most
nominations I believe for Game of
Thrones tonight how does that feel that
feels good it feels good but we have to
win a few good but winning is I don't
know it's tough competition I mean I got
dragons but we're facing robots and
handmaids and spies I mean that's it's
tough stuff man it's good to see the
cast back at the show and you know we
had like a cycle where they weren't
around and everybody missed you guys so
now we're back and of course I'm sure
people come up to all the time and say
what's gonna happen in that final season
what do you know I know a lot that I'm
not telling how would you describe it
remember I'm writing the books so I have
to get a book out and then another book
and what happens in the show and what
happens in the in the books will they be
the same will they be different you'll
have to watch and find out but I know
you know what's going on I know they
tell you in New York
yeah but I'm sworn to secrecy what about
if you could describe the final season
in one word what would come to your mind
bittersweet bittersweet like cocaine the
end of Lord of the Rings which I always
found that a wonderful bittersweet
quality that's the kind of thing I like
does that mean we're gonna see some very
critical character deaths no comment did
you when you heard some of the poem all
men must die
Valar morghulis when you heard some of
what was plans did you get emotional
about it well you know Chris possibly
based on what I planned so yeah I got I
got emotional about it 20 years ago when
I first thought on some of these things
what is it like for you to see the cast
tonight how much fun is it for you to
get together with that oh it's it's
great I wish more of them could be here
you know I know Maisie Williams and
sophie Turner are off doing doing new
movies so they're not here and simple
Kelly my dear friend she she was killed
on the show several years ago so she
can't be here but it will be great to
see Nikolai and Lena and and all of that
and Harrington newly married
yes and that's my fault yes I brought a
mechanic I wrote Jon Snow and Ygritte
and you know I got them together and
they fell in love they had a sex scene
and next thing you know the actors are
getting married they have you to thank I
hope they thank you the way they I hope
so too
I told captain what if I'd written a
love scene with a different actress he
who knows it would be marrying